happy New Year have you resolved to do
certain things differently this year I'm
sure many of you have well the libs have
too there are major woke New Year's
resolutions going all around tick tock
and we have the top three at least
according to my producers this video
brought to you by expressvpn more from
them later but first without any further
Ado let's get to the resolutions
good morning Saints and eights happy New
Year let's start the new year off right
white people
call your white family members and
friends out today for their racist
Antics why hold off tomorrow
which you can do today knock them out or
cuss them out I don't care just do it
and if you've already been doing that
keep up the good fight happy 2023. y'all
have a blessed day
I'm still stuck on Saints and ain't I've
never heard that I suspect though that
her advice is geared much more toward
the ain'ts just judging by what she said
afterward all of liberalism is just
screw you Dad right that's all this is
about she's saying yeah she a very white
woman saying yeah you gotta call up all
your white family members especially you
Dad thank you so much Dad and you gotta
cuss him out and hit him and I'm just so
angry and it's so terrible I hate them I
hate my dad
that's all that's all it comes down to
it's just I hate my dad if that's the
resolution I don't think it's going to
be a whole lot different for these Libs
than any other year in the past let's go
to number two white people
white people out there I'm talking to
you I need you to be a race Trader as we
go forward in this new year you've got
to do everything you can to make sure
that all the other quote white people in
your neighborhood in your network are as
uncomfortable as you once were when you
watch George Floyd die on video for nine
minutes as uncomfortable as you were
when you finally understood the
difference between individual racism and
systemic racism have honest
conversations it'd be the most kind and
decent person in the room while you
guide them through that discussion ask
some uncomfortable questions like is
there such a thing as white culture I
mean sit with that for a second imagine
a room with white people taking on a
question is there such a thing as white
culture step up your game we have to do
more my friends we're remaking this
country you guys be well and have a
great start to your week I don't know
about all those questions but this guy
definitely proves the answer to one of
those questions which is do white people
have a culture the answer is yes this is
it this is the white culture there's
many other aspects to White culture this
is probably the most distinctive one
only white people
prattle on and on and on about how
terrible they are they are the white
people are the only people in the
history of the world ever to do that and
I have some Authority here because
though I am broadly white my ancestors
are from Sicily the Sicilians have
always been a racially ambiguous people
a liminal people and so I think I've got
enough swarthiness that I can have a
little outside perspective here it is so
bizarre that white people uniquely hate
themselves for being white that that is
the proof that there is a white culture
that is this man has just accidentally
proved racial differences in his
self-flagellation this was borne out by
data there was a study done by Pew
research on racial Consciousness for
black people
70 plus said that race was somewhat or
very important to their identity for
Hispanic and Asian people the number was
north of 50 more than half of them said
that race was somewhat very important to
their identity white people
15 white people have basically no racial
consciousness
whatsoever
and in as much as white people are
gaining racial Consciousness it would
seem that they are only gaining racial
Consciousness to think about how
terrible they are this is the only group
of people that does that
this man is afflicted by it as well I
think by far the least comfortable
person here is this man it's too bad he
should be comfortable it's a new year it
could be a new hymn not good to feel
weak and sad and angry and depressed and
hate yourself all the time we've got to
protect ourselves you got to protect
your data online it's extremely
important to protect your online privacy
with a VPN choosing a VPN that you trust
is equally important the VPN that I
trust that I have trusted for years that
I've put on my devices on my mobile
devices on my laptop expressvpn I can
say with full confidence that expressvpn
is the best VPN on the market here's why
number one expressvpn does not log your
online activity other cheap or free vpns
make money by selling your data and
advertisers not expressvpn they even
developed a trusted server technology
that makes it impossible for their
servers to store any data at all number
two speed expressvpn has engineered a
new VPN protocol that makes user speeds
faster than ever you can even stream HD
videos with zero buffering number three
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use you
just heard me talk a lot about technical
features you don't need any technical
skills to get started I am a Luddite
okay I cannot work technology you just
fire up the app you click one button to
connect that's it it's super easy
Business Insider The Verge all these
guys talking about how great expressvpn
is protect yourself with the VPN I trust
use my link expressvpn.com Michael YT
today and get three months free in a
one-year package
expresvpn.com Michael YT expressvpn.com
Michael YT all right let's get back to
the woke resolutions New Year's
resolutions for white people these are
things we can all collectively work on
number one let's stop pretending that we
can't pronounce people's ethnic names
and really try hard to learn how to
pronounce them because it's really not
that difficult if you can pronounce
Worcestershire you can pronounce per car
is that how you pronounce
I thought it was
Worcestershire maybe you're right I
guess I can't pronounce white names
either forget that I can't pronounce
non-white names I can't pronounce the
white names keep going number two let's
try our best to unlearn aave if we've
been using it and relearn wave
white American vernacular English I
promise you it's wonderful
for example instead of saying bet you
could say okie dokie instead of saying
bffr you could say what Incarnation
instead of saying per you can say
totally
and let's not forget
what ever major loser
don't say that n word also don't say
ghetto or ratchet
usually this is a euphemism for white
people just to mean black people ghetto
is an Italian word
this is Italian Erasure that this woman
is engaging in very very racist number
three stop using fetishizing language
when you are dating people of color for
example stop calling people exotic
again people use exotic as a euphemism
for non-white people and it's very
authorizing and very dehumanizing why is
exotic dehumanizing it's just exotic if
if a Nigerian guy were dating this white
woman in Nigeria
that would be exotic for him they would
probably talk about how that was a
little exotic and unusual they would
probably chatter about that amongst
themselves that wouldn't be dehumanizing
it would be other Rising but but that
woman would be other than the majority
of Nigeria though she would be a little
exotic she might have I thought
diversity was a good thing aren't we
isn't that good to be exotic isn't it
good to be unusual isn't it good to be
unique no it's only good when it
subverts the culture and it's only bad
when it upholds the culture is that
basically especially when it comes to
sexual stuff but all the race politics
all the everything all of it's just
there's no rule there's no principle
whatsoever about any of these Concepts
it's just anything that
straight white Christian guys who are in
any way conservative and traditional
whatever they do is bad whatever they
want is bad and whatever they they don't
do and whatever they don't want whatever
other people want that's always good and
that's it that's the only principle stop
comparing people to food so stop saying
I like chocolate men or I like caramel
women it's like
do people say that has anyone ever asked
for a nice you know caramel little
Michael you know has anyone ever asked
or give me some of that give me a nice
tall drink of olive oil over there with
that little Mr Michael I don't know I've
never heard that I have not been privy
to those conversations keep going stop
saying I've never tried a blank before
just approach people normally just be
like hey I think you're cute one way to
avoid this problem would be to not be
promiscuous I've never tried uh so and
so before oh yeah I've never tried maybe
I'll sample so and so on Tuesday and
then go ahead and Sample such and such
on Thursday what you could do this is
going to be much more controversial than
any of the racial commentary in this
ladies video
you could be chaste and modest
and not treat people like their items at
a buffet that would and then you don't
need to worry about the language because
you're not engaging in the behavior
number four stop hoarding wealth
redistribute your wealth if you can
afford 20 Bath and Body Works candles or
every shade of Hydro Flask
you can afford to vemo your black
friends that is the demarcator of wealth
listen man if you're like Rich Uncle
Penny bags over here and you got it you
know you really got it like you can buy
multiple Bed Bath and Beyond candles
it's not real estate holdings not stock
portfolio it's Hydro what is a Hydro
Flask I don't know but I maybe I'm not
rich enough number five stop
perpetuating colorism
it can have dangerous consequences this
is things such as equating darker skin
to masculinity and strength and seeing
Oh I like dark skin because they're more
masculine or whatever that sounds like a
good thing I expected her to say the
dark skin you have to stop colorism and
suggesting the dark skin is bad but then
she said you have to stop suggesting
that dark skin is good so what you
you've got you've got to cut cut out
complimenting black people you got to
call them little wimps you just call all
those black men wimps and that's going
to be much less racist for 2023. and
then like saying oh light-skinned dudes
are more feminine this is bad because it
can lead to things like misogynoir it
can lead to things like water skin black
people not getting as much pain
medication because it's believed that
they're more tough like there's just a
lot that's wrong with it and there's
just no reason to do all that I'm sure I
missed a whole lot so
um if anyone has anything extra leave it
in the comments
okay I want to get back to the top one I
didn't realize she'd be going through
that litany like that the top one where
she says white people we need to stop
pretending like we can't pronounce
people's names and then she used an
English word that I actually can't
pronounce and I bet you can't either
what do you call the sauce
I don't know I can't say that
furthermore though would she apply that
same principle to foreigners who come to
our country who can't pronounce my name
do we need to apply this equally and say
hey Pedro you know stop calling me
Miguel it's Michael Michael John Knowles
I don't yeah I don't care that you
struggle to speak English
I don't you better pronounce that name
like the queen herself I want RP Michael
news no we wouldn't we wouldn't do that
so as always these are just ways to
attack white people for being white
people but but furthermore it is good
to mispronounce foreign words when you
were speaking English I've made this
point before and I will make it again
when I go to an Italian restaurant I am
of Italian extraction I speak the
Italian language I've spent plenty of
time in Italy when I go to an Italian
restaurant though I don't sit down there
with my menu and the waiter comes over
and he says do you know what she wants
her to say oh yes I think I'll have a
nice bowl of spaghetti carbonara
no I don't do that I sound like the
spaghetti yeah the carbonara Spaghetti
would be good and could you get me okay
I'll have um some nice little appetizer
I don't sound like the antipast o you
don't do that okay but they expect us to
do and the lips don't care when we
mispronounce Italian things because the
Italians are considered white but they
they get really upset when we
mispronounce Spanish things which is
funny because Spaniards are also white
but Latinos are not entirely white and
so they it's a middle round so they
expect me to go to a restaurant and say
I would like Los Tacos
and I that's not no we're speaking
English here and so even someone like
Alexandria ocasio-cortez who was born in
America and grew up in a very wealthy
suburb actually one town over from where
I grew up in the poorer town I grew up
in the porter Township in the more
expensive one but she pretends that
she's Jenny From the Block and she she
wants to go around and I think it is a
good thing to anglicize her name Ellis
Island was a good thing it is good that
Ellis Island tried to americanize people
if you're going to come here then you've
got to take on a character of the nation
my favorite one she was my favorite
because the first two just seemed so
weak but I gotta I got a real kick out
of her she was talking about you know
all sorts of I don't know and then she
she got kind of offensive in many places
and I got a real kick out of her hers
were my favorite resolutions for the
year what was yours let me know in the
comments below we'll see you next time
[Music]